my name is Joe and I'm a nymphomaniac
sex addict we say sex addict I am a
nymphomaniac and I love my filthy
[Music]
sexuality is the strongest force in
human beings to be born with the
forbidden sexuality in this agonizing I
love you Joe I love you I love you
wildness when you buy a tiger right you
also have to feed it satisfy it saying
it should have sex with others that man
you are to ask him if he wants to have
sex with me there was a world father
mine I had to explore here your name is
Fido she don't take my clothes off I'll
tell you what to do
and then get my knife back that's not
how it goes
most people don't scream until I hit
them I'm looking for a job I believe I
possess some qualifications and I'm
rather unscrupulous I know about your
qualifications and they're excellent
[Music]
no one can remove their sexuality even
though it's destroying everything for me
you were a woman demanding her right and
you reacted aggressively almost like a
man and you fought back
it's very touching all this then you've
probably misunderstood the whole thing
[Music]
you
[Music]